you
but thanks to our thanks all of you for
for being here it's great to be here I
want to encourage you I'm going to write
on the chalkboard so so I encourage you
to to come up where you can see and read
what what I'm writing I won't be
smashing any watermelons so it's
front-row is safe so Archimedes lived a
long long time ago
so he died in 212 BC and we know that
exactly because he died in the sack of
Syracuse so he lived in Syracuse and
peace and and when when the soldiers
came into the city they they knew about
him they knew about him he was a famous
man because he had been defending the
city he learned how to make parabolic
reflectors and set the sails of ships on
fire and he learned how to build cranes
that could reach down and and flip ships
upside down so so when people tried to
invade the city of Syracuse they had a
lot of trouble just getting on shore so
he defended the city for 35 years
and and they came into the they
eventually greets the woloson and they
came into the city and they found him
and he was drawing diagrams in the sand
and a soldier of a Roman soldier named
Marcellus King came up to him and and
and demanded to know who he was and and
realizing that he was Archimedes he said
ah I have to take this person to to the
general because this is the the fierce
defender of the city and and Archimedes
said no no step away don't disturb my
circles and so Marcellus killed him so I
thought in celebration of Archimedes we
could just fill the whole room with sand
and we could draw our mathematics in the
sand but that didn't fly so we'll do the
chalkboard instead and this is this is a
special year for Archimedes if you were
alive he would be 2,300 years old this
year
very good
one of the famous stories about
Archimedes is him running through the
through the streets of Syracuse yelling
Eureka so why did he discovered so he
was he was in he was in the bath and and
he had discovered the law of buoyancy he
realized that as he sank down into the
water the water pushed back up on him
and that's why he felt like he wasn't so
heavy when he was when he was deep in
the water and he realized even more he
realized exactly how much the water
pushed up on him
the force of the water pushing up on him
was equal to the weight of the water
that he had displaced why was he
thinking about this what what what was
what was the issue why didn't he care so
he was used famous already for being a
smart young man so he so he was he had
just finished school and he was known as
as the smartest kid in Syracuse and the
King had just had a crown built so a
crown made out of gold and he had handed
a chunk of gold to a famous famous
goldsmith and said he can build me a
nice crown out of out of this gold and
he got the crown and it was really
beautiful it was really nice but he just
had this sneaking suspicion that
something wasn't quite right
it just didn't feel right to him so the
King thought that the Goldsmith had
mixed something in with the gold maybe
silver if you mix a little silver in
with gold it's kind of hard to tell the
difference and then the goldsmith could
have kept the rest of the gold for
himself and he'd be a wealthy man so the
King wanted to know how can I figure out
whether the crown is really made out of
gold without destroying the crown and
there's a lot of valuable work has gone
into making this crown beautiful and how
will I tell so this is what Archimedes
was thinking about so let's go ahead and
do this computation for ourselves how
are we going to how are we going to tell
whether
whether a crown is made out of gold or
gold mixed with silver and the key thing
that they all knew at this time was that
gold is denser than Silver's so the same
volume of gold weighs more than the same
volume of silver so any guesses how did
you tell great okay so so you could make
you could make a gold crown that you
knew was pure gold to compare it with
and and put them in water and then what
are you going to do once they're in
water mmm okay so the question is maybe
one of them floats and one of them
doesn't and if one of them closed then
that's definitely going to be the big
round that's a good idea
unfortunately silver and gold both sink
they're both much heavier than water so
even if it were all silver would still
sink to the bottom but here's what a lot
of people think Archimedes might have
done they think he might have put them
in water and then see how much the water
rises right so so if silver is less
dense than gold
then equal weights of silver and gold
the silver will have more volume and the
water will rise more so let's let's do
this this computation so so say you had
a crown made out of gold and they
actually have crowns made out of gold
from around this time and they weigh
between 700 grams and the kilo so just
to keep our numbers round let's let's
pretend it's one kilogram a thousand
grams that's how much the crown weighs
and I can tell you that gold is about 19
point
three grams for cubic centimeters so
water is one gram per cubic centimeter
so gold weighs almost 20 times as much
per volume as water so then we should
say well how much gold is there so if we
have a thousand grams of gold and it's
nineteen point three grams per cubic
centimeter we want to know how many
cubic centimeters of gold do we have so
we divide and you'll find that you have
about 50 1.8 cubic centimeters of gold
so that's our crown so that's what a
true crown that's how much gold there
would be in the true crown
now what if what if it was 30% silver so
if we had just 700 grams of gold and we
had 300 grams of silver so the gold is
still 19 point three grams per
centimeter cubed but silver is much
lighter it's about half as dentist so
silver is about ten point nine grams for
tempered to exempt so if you go ahead
and divide 700 by 19.3 you have about
thirty six point three cubic centimeters
of gold and you have 300 divided by ten
point nine so oh sorry ten point five
and so this is about twenty-eight cubic
centimeters of silver and so you add
them up and you have here 64 cubic
centimeters of metal in this crown
that's seventy percent gold and thirty
percent silver so the difference is
about 13 cubic centimeters
so--that's hmm that's just what it is
so now say we're going to take these two
crowns and put them in water so how big
a tub of water do we need how big is it
crap
three feet across too big one inch
across too small so what would you say
about a foot okay good so let's say
about a foot across so if it's about a
foot across how many centimetres in the
foot thirty okay good so we have about
thirty centimeters across so the radius
is going to be about 15 centimeters so
here's our pool of water so our radius
is 15 centimeters and so we want to
compute so we have our tub of water so
15 squared is 225 times pot so PI R
squared is the area of this tub so PI R
squared so in 3.14 times 225 that's
about roughly eight hundred eight
hundred square centimeters
so if we have 13 extra cubic centimeters
so we put you put our crown in and we
have so if we put in 52 cubic
centimeters of gold how much is this
Waterman arrives
so 50 cubic centimeters so this is about
800 centimeters squared times how many
centimeters
about 1/16 16 times 50 is about a
hundred so it's going to go up about a
sixteenth of a centimeter that's not so
much what about for the big crowd so
when we put the big crown in so now we
have to ask ourselves well 64
centimeters to services about 800
centimeters squared times how much so it
looks like maybe 8 over 100 so what's 8
over 100 that's like 2 over 25
did I do the Metro
these two numbers are kind of small
right
okay so the difference between these is
going to be too small to tell yes there
have to be room for the king's head it
doesn't they are in the middle of the
crown there does so you don't have to
use this nice big part of the center oh
I see ah so good good so we could try to
exclude part of the center and make a
ring shape tub to put them in good so
there might be some way to adjust this
to make it work but I'm going to tell
you here and now this isn't what
Archimedes did there's no way you need
to have a whole nother kilo of gold on
hand to make this work right this gold
is too valuable but you don't have an
extra pound to compare this crown is
something precious you can't just make
another one to check against the one you
have it's so what was Archimedes doing
in the tub so Archimedes understood
buoyancy and he understood one other
thing he understood the principle of the
lever so what's the principle of the
lever so if you have a balance and you
hang something on the balance at some
distance D and you have some mass M then
when this hangs down it exerts so this
ya
it exerts a force it exerts a moment
about the fulcrum and the moment is
equal to the mass times the distance and
so if we have two weights hung at
different distances so if we have a big
mass we should hang it at a small
distance and these are going to be in
balance if the two masses times the
distances are the same so if little m
times Big D is equal to Big M times
little D that's a balance so what if
Archimedes only had a small chunk of
gold so he had a hundred grams of gold
yes yeah right so if he has just a
hundred grams of gold that's his tenth
as much gold as was was supposed to be
in the crown but he could hang it ten
times as far away so so let's make this
type of balance that Archimedes would
made so here he has a little lump of
gold maybe a hundred grams and he's
going to hang it far away from the
center and then close to the center he's
going to hang the crown
and now it's in Dallas so now what so
this is the principle of the lever but
his big discovery that moment the reason
why he shouted Eureka was because he had
discovered Quincy so what would happen
if both the crown and the Nugget were
made of pure gold and they were balanced
like this and we took the whole lever
and put it in the bathtub
so there's your thought experiment what
happens if you take this whole thing and
put it in the back what would happen
here if this was a hundred grams of
styrofoam on one end and you have the
crown would it still be balanced when
it's hanging in the air yeah right
it's just the match how much mass is
there 100 grams of styrofoam weighs just
as much as a hundred grams of gold it's
just a lot bigger so now when you put
that in the water what's going to happen
yes yeah it's not going to be a balance
anymore the crumbs going to sink and
this oh and the styrofoam would go way
up yeah yes the styrofoam wants to float
so if this is balanced and they're made
out of different materials then it will
fall out of balance once it goes into
the water and the less dense one is
going to want to rise so this was how
Archimedes tested the crown so he took a
bump of a hundred grams of gold and hung
it on the lever ten times as far away
from the crowd and unfortunately for the
crown maker disarmed sunk and the crown
went up the crown wasn't made of gold
I'll make a dive
Archimedes died too eventually so it's
no laughing matter but huh okay so okay
so that's what Archimedes did with
levers and buoyancy so what so this is
one half of the method of Archimedes so
the key to what Archimedes was doing was
that he was thinking in terms of
and he was thinking in terms of lemony
so for a long long time there was a
stone just outside of Syracuse that had
dissin scribed on it so it was a half of
a square so a rectangle that was twice
as wide as it is tall and it had inside
of it a triangle and I had inside of it
a half of a circle so this was this was
what Archimedes asked to have inscribed
on his tombstone
this was his proudest mathematical
achievement was to understand this
picture and not this picture in the
plane so before Archimedes there was
Euclid and Euclid was very good at
playing geometry he knew how to compute
areas of shapes in the plane but that's
two-dimensional mathematics and
Archimedes wanted to take that a step
further and he said what if you take
these three figures a triangle a half
circle and a rectangle and spin them
around so spin them around the vertical
line and what you get so if you spin a
rectangle you get a cylinder you spin
the triangle you get a cone
and if you spin half a circle you get
half of a sphere
and one of our community's great pure
mathematical accomplishments was to
understand the volume of these three
shapes how their volumes relate to one
another so think for a moment so so the
volume of the cone is it more or less
than the sum that's good is it more or
less than the hemisphere less because it
fits inside good roughly how much of of
the cylinder is filled up by the cone
3/4 know how much 5/8
okay so 5/8 for the cone work for the
hemisphere for the cone okay and for the
hemisphere
okay so maybe five-eighths for the cone
maybe six days for that could there be a
pie involved right what'd you think
about the areas right how are the areas
related how much of the area is the
triangle inside the rectangle ah right
good
so half and now as we spin it around how
much of the area of the triangle is
close to the center is more of the
triangle close to the center or is one
of the triangle far from the center most
of the time goes far from the center so
if I if I make a little strip here and
if I make a little strip here which
strip is bigger the strip this closer to
the center and then when I spin them
around which one is going to make a
bigger piece when it spins around the
small one right is going to spin around
further it's going to make a bigger
chunk in the coma good okay so do you
think the triangle when you spin it
around and make a cone is it going to be
half the volume more than half the
volume or less than half
let's draw another picture so we take
our rectangle let's say we choose half
of the rectangle in a different way so
here's the center let's say we take this
half the half I shaded it and spin that
around after you spin it around is the
volume half more than half or less than
that yes
so so you're right it's half in this
picture let's look at it from above so
let's take it let's let's fly up above
this picture and let's look down on the
cylinder from above so now we shade in
the half that's on the outside we shade
in so from the center we go halfway out
and then we shade in the rest of the way
and now if you take a wedge which part
of the wedge is bigger the one that's
shaded right the outer part the wedge is
getting wider as you go out do you see
what's happening as you spin around then
even though these two areas are equal
the inner area and the other equal area
the outer area is sweeping out a bigger
volume as it rotates around so here if
you spin this around the outer part is
going to be more than half even though
it's only half the earth okay so this
triangle more of its area is close to
the center and less of the area is far
from the center and so when you spin it
around even though it's half the area
it's going to end up being less than
half the body
so do you know the volume of a cylinder
do you know a formula for the volume of
a cylinder good ok so PI R squared which
is the area of the base times the height
very good and the cone exactly it's 1/3
so a cone is 1/3 the area of the base
outside and this is something that you
could do so this was known before
Archimedes and there's a really nice way
of seeing it so you imagine taking your
circle and you cut it up into little
triangles and so then you take your cone
and your Cohen gets cut up into
triangular color and you can take this
triangular cone and put it inside a
prison so a prism is just a triangle
moves straight upwards and so it's
volume is the area of the base times the
height and then you can cut this time
your prison into three pieces each of
which has the same volume and they fill
up the whole prism so you could do this
and so then you put them all together
and you get that the cone is there the
area of the base times
so now let's think again about the
hemisphere so what what portion of the
area off the rectangle is filled up by
the area of half a circle so let's say
this is one unit high so the radius is
one what's the area of the rectangle
anyway I hear - I hear - somewhere so -
yes don't be shy okay so the rectangle
is - and what's the area of the
hemisphere that any circle half a circle
pi over 2 right so if the area of a
circle is PI R squared and this is the
radius is 1 so the area of the full
circle is pi so the half circle has area
PI over 2 so the ratio is PI over 2 over
2 is PI over 4 so a little more than 3/4
now when you spin them around is it
going to be more or less than 3/4 okay I
see someone
thumbs down it's going to be less right
just like the cone the circle is taller
near the middle and shorter near the
edge so it's going to be less than 3/4
so before Archimedes no one knew what
the what the volume would be and it's a
hard problem so it's a calculus problem
to compute volumes this is why calculus
is very good that then someday you will
learn calculus and I gave this problem
to my calculus students in the fall so
so Yale sophomores and juniors and about
half of them could do the internet it's
not an easy integral
so even 2,300 years later with all the
math we've learned it's not such an easy
computation to do but our committees had
a clever way of doing this so he said
well if I can't compute the volume of a
sphere maybe I can compute something
else and his something else
so another Eureka moment for him was he
decided that if he hung the sphere on a
balance that he could compute the moment
of the sphere about the focus so this is
some four-dimensional quantity it's a
volume times of distance the volume is
three-dimensional the distance is one
dimensional so there was some
three-dimensional integral that he could
not do and he replaced it with a
four-dimensional integral that he knew
how to do and so he said well so he took
a sphere of radius R and it turns out
that he wanted to hang it at distance 2r
so twice the radius from from the folks
this is just what he decided to do and
what he said was well as I go I can
think of my sphere as being made out of
slices and as I take slices going down
the sphere at least at the beginning the
slices are getting bigger and so the
moment of each slice about the fulcrum
is going up it said well on the other
side let me put something else and
there's something else that he chose was
a cylinder
so you put for the cylinder on the other
side and he decided instead of slicing
the cylinder from top to bottom he
sliced the cylinder from left to right
and so now all the slices have the same
size but as you move from left to right
they're further from the fulcrum so they
exert a greater moment about the filter
and he might have even built a balance
like this and what you'll find is that
it's not so in the cylinder that he
chose a radius 2 R and length 2 R and
it's not in balance and you can see that
it's not going to be in balance as you
come down the slices start getting
smaller here what Archimedes realized
was that the difference between these
two was exactly a cult and so when he
drew this picture what he was expressing
was that he thought he fully understood
the relationship between a cone a
hemisphere and a soul so this cone as
radius 2 R and height you are an
Archimedes just tells us that these are
in balance yes you said he understood
that the difference was the column yes
how did he understand that he was a
genius of the greatest order
there's there's some things that that
that one can't explain he lived for 75
years he was he was a truly brilliant
man and he thought and thought and
thought all the time
and and this was something that in the
course of his research he saw and
understood so he didn't have algebra so
he wasn't able to write things out in
equations the way that we can uh we can
go ahead and use our equations and
understood and understand what what he
saw so so let's do that so as we go
slicing these three objects were going
to slice the cylinder from left to right
and the sphere and the cone from top to
bottom and so let's take our slice at
distance X so at time X we take this
slice and the area of this slice so the
a circle with radius 2 R the area is
going to be pi times the radius squared
so pi times 2r squared so on the
cylinder side we have 2 pi and 2 R
squared and times the distance and the
distance now is X that's how far the
slices from now on this side we're going
to have to think for a moment let's do
the cone first because the cone is
easier so the cone has height 2 R and at
the bottom it has radius 2 R and the
radius is increasing steadily from 0 to
2 R so when we do the slice at height X
the radius will be
okay so we have pi x squared times what
times the distance to R so that doesn't
look anything like what's over here
right here we have an R squared times an
X and here we have an x squared times an
R this looks like trouble but we still
have this fear yes when you wrote pi x
squared times 2r weren't you using
something more than all of each of those
disks is 2r ah oh good good question
that's right not the whole disk is that
distance to are from the fulcrum
but Archimedes understood that any mass
behaves like a point mass at its center
of gravity
and so this disk has a symmetry and so
the center of the disk is the whole disk
will behave like its entire mass
concentrated at its center of gravity
Amy yeah
so here now we have to do something a
little bit trickier we need to compute
what's the area of this slice of the
sphere so we can go back to what we know
about algebra so so we have a circle and
we're going to put the circle and the
point R zero in the place so that as we
start at time zero we have a slice and
so when we take the slice at distance X
we want to know how high is the slice so
the equation for this circle so you
might know is so if you have a circle
centered at 0 0 is x squared plus y
squared equals R squared but here we've
moved everything to the right arm so
instead of X its X minus R so X minus R
squared plus y squared is equal to R
squared and we can expand this out so
it's x squared minus 2x R plus R square
plus y square is equal to R squared and
the R Squared's cancel so those go away
and you have Y squared equals 2x R minus
x squared
and so this why so this is this is what
we're interested in why is the height of
that slice there which is the radius of
our circle here so when we have pi x y
squared that's pi x 2 XR minus x squared
and again so the center of this disc is
that distance to R so now we add up
what's happening on the left so we have
4 PI X R squared minus 2 pi x squared R
plus 2 pi x squared R so these cancel
and this is what we're left with 4 PI X
R squared which is exactly what we have
on the right so this is what our
community saw he saw that these were in
balance and so now that he knows that
they're in balance he can go ahead and
solve for the volume of a sphere so he
knows the volume of a cylinder and he
knows that its center of mass but yet
distance R in the fo'c'sle and he knows
that the volume of the cone
you see that that now we know enough to
solve for the volume of the sphere so on
the right hand side the volume of the
cylinder is the area of the base times
side the height is 2r and the area of
the base is pi times the radius squared
so we have the height which is 2r times
the area of the base which is pi times
2r squared
I guess question okay could I just ask
you to show the first slice again of
each that you're adding up and before
you proceed along index the expression
that you wrote
yeah or the slice on the top of this
here the top of the sphere so this
distance is accent in the top of the
column
this is axe and the left side of the
cylinder yes and you just and they're
all the same as you go yes and there's
some leap of faith that if each of these
slices is balanced then the whole object
should be down our communities did not
accept this as a proof yeah so there's a
wonderful story behind this so argument
ease did not accept this as a fruity
useless to figure out what the volume of
the sphere was and then once he knew the
answer he found another way of proving
that it was correct and then he did this
and he didn't tell anyone how he had
actually done it and shortly before he
died he wrote it down so in between
times he was writing letters to his
friends in other cities and he was
taunting them he was saying I know the
volume of a sphere then when they didn't
respond after a few years he would tell
them what the volume was I didn't say
can you guess how I have I got this one
so eventually he wrote it down
and we lost it we lost it so it was and
then we found it again so so the one
copy that we have where Archimedes
explains this picture was written in
year 987 so is written down in in
Byzantium and 987 like in Greek it was
copied down and paper at that time was
extremely valuable and over the years
what Archimedes had said seemed less and
less important and other things became
more important and so they washed they
washed the paper so they could reuse it
so they went ahead and washed off
everything that was written about this
addiction and and they wrote a religious
text on top of it and so that was that
was done in year 12 2008
and in 1840 a Bible scholar a biblical
scholar traveled to what was then
Constantinople now Istanbul and found
this text and and read it and and
thought it was interesting so so he was
studying the the religious content of
the text and he brought a page home to
Cambridge and a Danish language scholar
saw this page he was a philosophy was
interested in the historical use of
language and he saw that there was this
this mathematical writing underneath and
he recognized it as Archimedes and so he
traveled to Constantinople to see the
rest of this text
his name was Heiberg and so in 1906 he
he took photographs of the entire text
page by page he took he took photographs
and he brought them back to Denmark
and he wrote about them and so over the
next ten years he published his
transcriptions of what was written in
these lost texts of Archimedes and then
we lost it again it disappeared from
1920 until 1998 so many of you who are
not alive then but I remember when this
book came on auction it was in the New
York Times that they had rediscovered
this book it had been sitting in
someone's basement in France for 70 some
years it had been defaced so someone had
had added counterfeit counterfeit
Byzantine paintings to a few pages
trying to increase the value of this
manuscript but it was found and now we
have all this technology so infrared
reflectography and and x-rays and
they've studied every page of this and I
mean now know an awful lot about what
was washed away so we can still read the
traces that's the only way we know that
Archimedes figured out that these solids
balance oh yeah so let's solve the
equation so what is the volume of scheme
on the right-hand side so let's expand
this out so we have so this is the area
of the base this is the height and the
distance of the center of gravity from
the fulcrum is R so when we expand this
out we have a 2 squared times a 2 so we
have an 8 so now let's do the cylinder
or s through the cone so the cone is at
distance 2 R from the center and this
volume is 1/3 the area of the base times
the height so 2 R times 1/3 now the area
of the base is again pi times 2 R
squared and the height is again 2 are
so if we multiply it out we have 2
squared is 4 times 2 is 8 times 2 is 16
divided by 3 so we have 16 over 3 or PI
times R to the fourth so 8 PI R to the 4
times minus 16 thirds PI R to the 4 is
the volume of the sphere times 2r so the
volume times 2r is equal to now what's 8
minus 16 over 3 you put everything over
a common denominator so 24 over 3 minus
16 over 3 is 8 over 3 this is 8 thirds
PI R to the fourth and now we can cancel
an R and make this an R cubed and we can
cancel it too and get a 4 so the volume
is 4/3 PI R cubed now if you cut the
sphere in half the volume of half the
sphere is 2/3 PI R cubed so here in this
picture the cone is 1/3 the volume of
the cylinder the hemisphere is 2/3 so
it's a very simple ratio it's just one
to choose this is this is what
Archimedes discovered this
and like yes you did this using algebra
right did but he didn't use L know he
just was able to do it because he was a
genius yes okay so one thing that any
mathematician worth his salt will tell
you is when you have a new method you
milk it for all it's worth
okay so Archimedes had a new way of
computing things that nobody else knew
and he used this to compute many many
things so he said well once we've taken
a triangle and half a circle and we can
spin those around and we can compute
their volumes what about a problem what
if what if we take the parabola and we
spin it around and then slice it so it
looks like that you can compute that the
volume of that and if you're going to
hang that on a lever you're gonna want
to know where the center of gravity is
right so where's the center of gravity
he'll tell you he'll tell you
where's the center of gravity of a
hemisphere right it's somewhere it's
somewhere on on this line but but where
how does it compare to the center of
gravity of a coma
okay so center of gravity of a cone if
you play with it she'll figure out the
center of gravity of a cone is is a
quarter of the way up now a hemisphere
is more top-heavy than the cone so it
should be higher up so something that's
so a good thing to play with where is
the center of God mean by hemisphere so
Archimedes
and the final thing that he computed by
his method was he looked inside the cube
and he inscribed two cylinders going in
perpendicular directions and he
intercepted them so take the
intersection of Easter cylinders and you
can think about what that looks like two
cylinders inside a cone and intersect
them if you look down from the top you
just see the hole you see a a square
right so do you see that that and this
at this section halfway up you get the
whole square and as you come down from
the top while you should think about
what you get as you as you come down so
what's the volume and the reason why our
communities love this particular
computation was all the other volumes of
round round objects that he knew so a
cone is is somehow round a cylinder is
round a sphere is round this paraboloid
is round and all of their volumes
involve pie and he knew that pie was
irrational so the volume of this
intersection of two cylinders it's
somehow a round shape but it's volume is
rational so if you do this inside the
unit two you get a rational button so I
leave that as a challenge for you to
think about what is the volume of the
intersection with two cylinders